People are often apprehensive about dealing with foreigners.
Here are some very basic suggestions that will make the encounter easier for both.
There are some basic rules that will always work well.
Etiquette such as standing up, holding the door open,...
...not avoiding eye contact and shaking hands firmly will make a client feel comfortable.
Don't be shy to ask questions to clarify situations, because this avoids confusion.
Clients appreciate commitment, punctuality and ethical business practices.
Know your client's food preferences when dining out and steer clear of talking about...
...politics, religion and personal issues.
Good topics would be their country, weather, sports, places to visit in your country and so on.
When you introduce yourself, not all cultures take the same business approach.
For example, you may get a better reception with a self-depreciating attitude than a self promotional one.
It is always better to check your clients' culture.